one of the most powerful features of
Android since the start of the platform
has been the ability to deliver timely
notifications to users we're going to
add a simple one to our weather app this
simple notification will show the
weather icon for the forecast the
forecast text and the high and low
temperature for the day one of the key
things we wanted to point out is how not
to be spammy with our notification our
app will display at most a single
notification it really wouldn't make
sense of these notifications stacked up
anyhow they don't display enough
information to give context the key
thing with notifications is to deliver a
useful morsel of information formatted
in a standard way
so that it harmonizes with the rest of
the system we'll start by adding a
string for the preference for the last
time we've sent a notification to the
user as well as a format string for the
body of the notification let's implement
the notification inside of our sync
adapter our notification will be based
upon what is in the database so we'll
create projection and column indices
values in our sync adapter for the
weather ID description Max and min
temperature let's add a function to
notify us of the weather
we'll add some additional constants up
here one for day in Millie's and one so
that we can use the same notification ID
reusing the notification ID means that
our application will only post at most
one notification and then finally we'll
call this function in a reasonable place
within our on performed sync function
inside of the sync adapter inside of
notify weather we'll check to see
whether or not we've actually shown
notification that day if we haven't then
we'll talk to the database get a cursor
for the Content resolver for the current
day and then fetch the data but one
thing we're not doing is actually
showing the notification all right we're
getting near the end implement a weather
notification build our notification
using notification compat dot builder
pointing to a pending intent built by
the v4 compatible task stack builder and
sent with the notification manager hint
an explicit intent to our main activity
is a good idea here there's lots of
documentation on this you'll want to
read